si la oposición concurre dividida y con
notables ausencias porque tanto navalny
que está seleccionaban y el principal
disidente ruso está ahora mismo
cumpliendo una pena de prisión y también
muchos de sus aliados que en los últimos
años han colaborado con él han quedado
vetado y fuera de estas elecciones la
posición tenía un as en la manga era el
voto táctico a través de una aplicación
que bueno ya que no pueden presentarse
muchos de los disidentes esa aplicación
indicaba a los votantes a quien podían
votar para conseguir por lo menos quitar
esa mayoría
presidencial quien era digamos en la
persona que estaba desafiando al partido
gubernamental el aspirante que tenía más
posibilidad de arrebatar ese escaño en
cada demarcación pero hoy tanto google
como apple han anunciado que retiran esa
aplicación de sus tiendas online así que
la posición vuelve a estar en parte
ciega y sin posibilidad de intervenir en
estos comicios ni de definir y empujar
en un sentido ni en otro el resultado de
estas elecciones